let's start the annual Jim Norton and
Sam Roberts Halloween parade okay here
comes someone are you excited
I am well I get to hold out a minute
longer than you because you can see them
coming in okay I can see grab the couch
Mike looks like okay I'm gonna take a
guess best based on the visual it's like
like a slightly more homoerotic geek
Troy Quan pretty much okay Tim from 90
day fiancé
[Laughter]
give Jennifer the D she's have a
backwards hat I know he had his hair I
do see that Troy tried to like point his
hair a little bit you put sunglasses on
and and who are we talking to here this
is a 90 day fiancé
do you like him oh you know what I did
after the tell-all I ended up liking him
so what happened with you and your
fiance what I want you and your fiancé
Tim I didn't give her the D you didn't
deliver and I didn't give her the D he's
to her fall to yours
it's my small penis okay okay looks like
Troy really got it I didn't realize I
never saw Tim from 90-day fiance wear
camo fatigues no we'll have that many
tattoos good biceps I've almost Adam
Levine if I could have found a jacket
you sure just come in here with no shirt
on it's okay well right now I guess Troy
is really lead yeah for best costume
yeah welcome to the show whoever you are
my name is Mike Iaconelli
who is Mike Iaconelli
big fisherman from New Jersey famous
fisherman dressed up as Mike fisherman
from New Jersey hey Tim from 90-day
fiance could you Google Mike Iaconelli
for us while you're over there uh is he
a very famous fisherman thank you Tim
yeah my canal he'll in fact she's never
heard of famous fisherman Mike Iaconelli
what type of fish do you like to fish
Mike largemouth bass you do where do you
catch them all over the country what
biggis joker you ever snagged 12 pounds
it's kind of shitty big bass isn't it
time for a prefer for a famous fisherman
think it'd be more than 12 or 12 pound
bass in a restaurant yeah yeah who else
is here today it's yeah it's the
Halloween parade who else is here this
is okay where's the music it's only for
specific okay good so far we've not we
so you were sure okay we're looking at
somebody you get my you can get the
booze as you kind of came in is that a
Gryffindor I'm a handy Potter I got hey
is that a Gryffindor robe you're wearing
huh okay I thought it was the mysterious
hot dog apparently it was Henny Potter
what does Gryffindor is that from the
movie it's for Harry from Harry Potter I
guess it's one of those rolls or
something and you carry a bottle of
alcohol it's Halloween it started oh
that's not part of the costume and it is
now you join that Hennessy honey Potter
okay good good who lost we who's next
yeah who's next in the parade in the big
grand parade let's see all right now
this is a classic it's actually a really
good costume it really is all right well
I know this music yeah and I see a guy
you know I love that Bart are you scared
where's my shirt I see you got a wife
beater he's got his brown leather belt
thought he's got the American flag tied
around his arm not awful dance that's
right which I think fits it fits
perfectly long blonde hair kind of
shitty goatee facial hair thing hat and
a and the blonde wig yeah it looks like
a wig no it's not yeah where are you
okay I see the sunglasses then the door
and everything where are you from
Detroit seats right yeah I see are you a
Democrat no no no no no very hardcore
conservative you like the president in
the troops oh yeah okay hmm let's see
who he be this is a costume it's a
really good kid right yeah
we're looking at you looking more like
Kid Rock and Kid Rock dust these days
well thank you yeah this is good
whoo I see a studio is playing
Susu dia sister he's a personal favorite
you like that one yeah why do you like
it so much I love Phil Collins I see a
man in a very very polished eighties
business suit he's got sunglasses on
perfectly quaffed haired blow-up doll
and a blow-up doll with a chainsaw in
hand [ __ ] on her back and there is some
blood on her back yeah uh what do you do
for a living sir well I'm into murders
and executions mostly mergers and
acquisitions yeah well I would imagine
this could be one of many people I mean
it could be Patrick Bateman but not that
not that loser right it's probably
somebody else yeah well I have been
known to go by Paul [ __ ] the other yeah
pull that one there it is there it is
nailed it nailed it and have more
confidence in yourself I think it's got
to be Paul Allen right certainly
definitely not Patrick loser
Patrick Bateman yeah oh what a dork
hey yeah what text is your business card
written in boom that's the color there
it is okay you got it you got it
we got Patrick Bateman I love it I love
it and I guess we just have one more one
more
yeah one more in the Big Jim Norton and
Sam Roberts Halloween parade and I sense
that he's coming no musical cue this
this is gonna be kind of a letdown oh
yeah what do you think about that
American Badass I mean it's not pretty
cool we're looking at somebody who's
wearing a hoodies a dress
she's got a wig she's got a my hair it's
in a messy bun with a scrunchie oh it is
and is that a Hydra flexcube got there
and I noticed there's some stickers on
it why don't you got a lot of scrunchies
around your wrist there no scrunchies
are cool I know yeah no they are and
what kind of backpack is that nice the
jowl raven KenKen of course it's a full
fledge and extremely dressed like half
the women I date yeah really
Travis would be a very convincing if he
had shaved down completely yeah you
would have had an argument with me as to
whether or not that was a true female I
got stuff in my bag you do okay visco
what's your are you just visco girl
you're just fiscal girl that's the worst
okay what do we have in your bag we're
pulling it out oh my god oh you have a
little it's the little boat right camera
that's a bigger one though that's nice
we literally discussed it in that first
hour he's got you've got a polar I mean
she's got a Polaroid camera yeah yeah
take photos of your friends now are you
are you triggered at all when you look
at Jim's coffee cup there's a plastic
straw in it you see okay it's replacing
this used that's good one more Jim and
Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app
[Music]